[Music]
I'm really excited we here in Moscow in
Russia in the Central has of scientists
of the Russian Academy of Sciences to
the ceremony to the naming of three of
the elements hundred and fifty one
hundred and seventeen hundred eighty and
I've got to make a speech in Russian I'm
a bit nervous but I hope to be right
[Music]
Oh
this element is unique in the periodic
table because it's never been observed
in any form at all so the fields wide
open this is after all what Mendeleev
cranks of the periodic table was that he
looked where they were holes in the
periodic table working reckon there
should be elements and he predicted
their property
if you really lucky little bit pull off
after one perfect loved another
I believe that some we will make
kilometer hundred patients like food
versus true folk in Russian in doubler
and mr. really exciting piece of news
had managed to make a new element the
most exciting thing from you about the
periodic table the happening since we
start to be secured so this is purely
table as we know it they haven't
actually officially proves the name yet
that they said this is the name of the
committee it would be missed
they like this into the center of the
target
[Music]
there's almost like a children's of you
spying it so Wow something new something
really exciting and now I will show you
how it looks like and I will open the
box
I'm very excited never seen anything
like this before so it's really a real
close for me I've never met anybody
who's discovered an element and you go
on throwing and throwing more and more
so now's the time to put in your bed the
main for element 117 I met a
representative of Brighton meconium must
go Liam Hennessy and agonist on but
certainly people get very passionate
about me
so one name is Russian and the other
name is American now the important
question that people will evoke is what
in Earthmen saponification
anything like this we will produce a
little radioactive liquid sample which
is testing theories and things like that
that william we fight for
we ask them development
afterwards there was cake and champagne
and
[Music]
here's a pioneer and very long time
researcher in the clan extremely
unlikely that it will happen again for
elements at once for very long time if
ever I thought this almost akin to to be
nation of Nobel Prizes and celebration
of good science so yes a really exciting
time
[Music]
[Applause]
Oh
[Music]
you
[Applause]
[Music]
in the beep come this way
the metaphor but King
[Music]